we have a verdict in the Johnny Depp
Amber Heard case and like everything in
the trial itself it's controversial the
jury ruled in favor of Johnny Depp in
his libel suit against Amber Heard Depp
sued his former wife for writing about
being a domestic abuse Victim Because he
said he never abused her the jury
awarded depth 15 million dollars in
Damages 10 million in compensatory
damages and 5 million dollars in
punitive damages the jury also ruled in
favor of Amber Heard on one of her
counter claims against Depp she alleged
that Deb directed A smear campaign
against her having his ex-lawyer saying
she fabricated the evidence of her abuse
the jury awarded her two million dollars
in compensatory damages and nothing in
punitives So at the end of the day they
both win hooray no but seriously how can
they both have defamed each other let's
dig into this verdict
now first of all and I I hate that I
have to say this no one is going to jail
this is a civil case and no one is
guilty people are liable in a civil case
they are not guilty or not guilty
despite what some putative law professor
has said this is a Civil Trial there's
no guilt involved now In fairness about
half the states do have a criminal
defamation statute including Virginia
but this is not one of those cases it's
just two people suing each other the
state is not involved but as you
probably know here we have two public
figures suing each other for defamation
and when you have celebrities you
generally have a higher standard of
proof to make your claim the law makes
it difficult for public people to win a
defamation suit even if a published
story contains inaccuracies in order for
a public figure to win the jury has to
find that the defendant made statements
about them with actual Mouse actual
Mouse means knowledge of the falsity OR
at a minimum a reckless disregard for
the truth of the statements it has
nothing to do with animosity now as you
probably know Amber Heard wrote an ope
in the Washington Post that contained
these sentences quote then two years ago
I became a public figure representing
domestic abuse and I felt the full force
of our culture's wrath for women who
speak out and quote I had the rare
vantage point of seeing in real time how
institutions protect men accused of
abuse now Johnny Depp challenged these
sentences and also the headline written
by The Washington Post itself quote
Amber Heard colon I spoke up about
sexual violence and faced our culture's
wrath that has to change debt suit heard
alleging these sentences were defamatory
and during closing arguments herd's
lawyer told the jury that if they
believe Depp abused her even one time
that he cannot prove defamation if Amber
was abused by Mr death even one time
then she wins now during deliberations
the jury had to evaluate the evidence
that they heard over the six-week trial
and apply the jury instructions given to
them by the judge with Depp's defamation
claims they were looking at instruction
C which you can see here so the jury had
to decide whether herd made or
republished any of these statements
these were false statements whether they
harmed his reputation and whether Amber
Heard acted with actual malice they
answered yes yes she said it republished
these words yes they were false and yes
they heard his reputation the jury
likely decided everything they ever
heard said about abuse was false and
that she did it with Reckless disregard
for the truth and as a result Johnny
Depp sustained about 15 million dollars
in Damages 10 million dollars in
compensatory damages which is meant to
compensate him for the damage that he
actually suffered as well as 5 million
dollars in punitives that is to punish
Amber Heard for her statements now the
judge cut the punitives down to 350 000
bringing the total to 10.35 million
dollars now those are obviously large
numbers but it kind of makes sense in
the context of Johnny Depp he is a
famous movie star and he alleges
probably probably truthfully that these
allegations have really hurt his career
and hurt his ability to make millions
and millions of dollars so it's entirely
possible that he lost 10 million dollars
as a result of the statements that Amber
Heard made against him and given the
general nature of herd statements the
fact that the jury found in depth's
favor probably means that the jury
likely didn't believe any of herd
substantive claims of abuse now some
have argued that herd got a raw deal
because her column did not mention debt
by name but Depp successfully argued
that it was an example of what's called
defamation by implication because parts
of the column referred to the
allegations of abuse that she made
against him following their breakup in
2016. and it's probably fair to say that
the general public knew about herd's
connection to Depp and that they would
have assumed that the allegations made
in the op-ed referred to debt because of
that connection and that she was
directing those statements at Johnny
Depp and there's plenty of law on this
this is not unusual for a defamation by
implication case and that takes us to
Amber heard's counter claims you'd think
that if her defamed death then they
would dismiss herd's claims and that
would be the end of the story but what
fun would that be as you know the jury
also found the depth defamed hurt but it
looks like that relates to a statement
only tangentially related to the main
abuse statements now after Depp sued
heard in 2021 she filed a counterclaim
against him she said that Depp directed
his ex-lawyer Adam Waldman to make
defamatory statements about her
including these three statement a quote
Amber Heard and her friends in the media
used fake sexual violence allegations as
both the sword and a shield depending on
their needs they have selected some of
her sexual violence hoax facts as a
sword inflicting them on the public and
Mr Depp statement B quote quite simply
this was an ambush a hoax they set Mr
Depp up by calling the cops but the
first step didn't do the trick the
officers came to the penthouses
thoroughly searched and interviewed and
left after seeing no damage to face or
property so Amber and her friends
spilled a little wine and roughed up the
place got their stories straight under
the direction of a lawyer and publicist
and then placed a second call to 9-1-1
statement C quote we have reached the
beginning of the end of Miss herd's
abuse hoax against Mr Depp and the jury
reviewed the evidence and with respect
to at least one of these statements
believed that that was the case
specifically they decided that statement
B the long paragraph about a specific
incidence was false the main facts about
that incident were relayed to the jury
by Hurd and her friends the very same
people that the jury found had
completely made up things in order to
hurt Depp now we'll need to hear from
the jury to understand exactly what they
were thinking but we can presume that
the jury reviewed the evidence and
concluded that Amber Heard and her
friends didn't orchestrate an abuse hoax
on that occasion maybe they didn't spill
wine or rough up the place they didn't
work with a lawyer or publicist they
might not have gotten their stories
straight if this is what the jury meant
then they could be claiming that the
underlying incident is still based on a
lie but that herd orchestrated the line
a different way or that she was lying
about other things and not this thing
but at the end of the day the jury
awarded two million dollars to herd for
this particular falsity these same
jurors probably found that she acted
with actual malice and concocting a hoax
that included fake bruises and fake
tears and fake claims and thus statement
A and C were therefore not defamatory
only statement B which referred to a
very specific tangential incident so
both Depp and herd were awarded
compensatory damages these are things
that are meant to compensate a plaintiff
to be in the same position that they
would be if they weren't injured things
like Financial losses medical bills lost
income and reduced earning potential and
a damage award can also consider
non-monetary losses as well like
emotional pain or physical pain loss of
companionship all of those would be
considered compensatory damages but
Johnny Depp was awarded punitive damages
as well which are designed to warn
others and punish this particular
defendant they are assessed when a jury
wants to punish someone who acted
totally outside the bounds of
appropriate conduct and they're only
available in Virginia if the defendant
has acted wantingly oppressively or with
such malice as to events a spirit of
malice or criminal indifference to civil
obligations but in Virginia punitive
damages are capped at three hundred and
fifty thousand dollars by Statute now
the jury found that Amber Heard had to
fame Johnny Depp and that her conduct
satisfied the very highest standard for
punitive damages now they awarded him a
lot of money five million dollars in
punitive damages but the judge reduced
that damages award to 350 000 as
required by Statute now the the jury
wouldn't have known that going into
deliberations that's to make sure that
they don't uh shift all of the punitive
damages into the compensatory damages
award but after the verdict was reached
the judge capped the amount that was
required by law tangentially you might
also hear lawyers referring to the State
Farm standard where punitive damages are
capped as a matter of constitutional law
uh that's a Supreme Court case that
doesn't apply here there was a specific
Statute in Virginia that limited
punitive damages to 350 000 that doesn't
really implicate the the State Farm
Supreme Court case that being said after
the punitive damages were capped Johnny
Depp was entitled to 10.35 million
dollars though Amber Heard was awarded
two million dollars in compensatory
damages related to the statement B that
we just talked about now adding Johnny
Depp 8.35 million dollars at the end of
the day so what's next can Johnny Depp
Sue The Washington Post well sure but
it's incredibly unlikely that he'd win
you can sue anyone for anything at any
time but there's no reason to believe
that the Washington Post would have
known of the falsity of the statements
and on top of that the Washington Post
simply published Amber heard's article
the only part of the article that was
written by The Washington Post was the
headline Amber Heard Cohen I spoke up
about sexual violence and faced our
culture's wrath that has to change which
more or less summarizes the things that
Amber Heard actually said so good luck
proving knowledge of falsity or
recklessness with respect to the truth
by The Washington Post itself though
given that the article is still online
Depp might sue for an injunction to take
that article down but by that same token
could Amber Heard sue the ACLU The
Washington Post published herd's op-ed
but the ACLU helped her write it hurt
had promised to donate seven million
dollars from her divorce settlement to
two Charities including the ACLU and so
far she's only paid the ACLU part of
that money could could she claim that
they did a bad job of ghost riding the
op-ed maybe negligence well again you
can sue anyone for anything at any time
sure this is theoretically possible but
it would be extremely complicated and
probably doomed though more tenuous
arguments have been made maybe heard
will use it to try and Claw back some of
her donation who knows complete
speculation but what about an appeal of
the jury's verdict Amber Heard has vowed
to appeal and even though Depp was also
found to have defamed heard Depp was not
surprisingly very pleased with the
verdict Depp said that herd's op-ed
changed his whole life in the blink of
an eye but the jury had given his life
back now heard was not pleased with the
verdict and said that she was
heartbroken that the mountain of
evidence still was not enough to stand
up to the disproportionate power
influence in sway of my ex-husband and
although people talk about what
precedent this verdict sets what lawyers
mean by precedent is different from how
regular people often use that word in
the law a precedent is set in by
published judicial opinions legally
speaking jury verdicts don't set any
precedent whatsoever you can't cite to
the Amber Heard case and hope that some
other jury or judge will follow it but
if the case goes up on appeal and there
is a written opinion that opinion would
have presidential effect which is one
reason potentially the parties might
settle before the appeal is completed uh
they might just do it to get rid of
uncertainty with what the court of
appeal might or might not do but no
doubt when this case goes up on appeal
you should read about it in today's
sponsor morningbrew because that's my
favorite way to catch up with pop
culture and the news I've actually been
subscribed to morning Brew for forever
it's one of my absolute favorite
newsletters and I'm thrilled to tell you
why because morning Brew if you didn't
already know is a free daily newsletter
delivered Monday through Sunday it gets
you up to speed on business finance Tech
and law in just five minutes and it
provides a fantastic quick survey of the
most important issues while being witty
irreverent and informative and did I
mention it's completely free this week I
learned all about why my stocks are
going down and then I learned more about
why my stocks are going down and oh my
God why are my stocks going down so much
but I also learned about nft insight are
trading at openc U.S inflation and the
Great American lifeguard shortage it's
basically exactly the mix of news that
I'm actually interested in and stuff I
didn't even know that I wanted to know
about and it's all written in a
hilarious style morning Brew is one of
the few emails that I actually open
every day so Legal Eagles this one is a
complete no-brainer morning Brew is
completely free and it takes less than
15 seconds to subscribe just click on
the link that's on screen right now or
in the description to get morning Brew
for free and not only will you get a
newsletter that you'll actually read
you'll actually help this channel too so
click on the link below to get morning
Brew right away and while you're at it
click on this link with all of my other
legal videos so click on this link or
I'll see you in court